good morning Millennials
good morning millennial welcome to the
number one morning show ever of all time
of all time not as good as the one in
good morning wonder boy what was it
called good morning oh [ __ ] I forgot
with Harrison Ford honestly but I mean
saying that we want to host like a
toaster movie night but that we should
and we should do it
Morning Glory would be a toast movie of
the week if the movie night oh wait let
me add it to my list cuz we keep saying
them Oh is today the day we're gonna
discuss the movie yes I mean - dude -
your toaster yeah we have a very busy
day Marco will be emailing us the best
of dear toes hold dear toasters do you
know the password
no I'll text it to you anyways we have
such a fun show free today sadly this is
our last show together for like so long
two weeks until mutton then until next
Monday so tomorrow Claudia's going to
Raleigh I will be co-hosting with Ben
but back by popular demand because I
actually I did ask him but it was just
so fun last week you guys loved it I
loved it he loved it so we're gonna do
it again tomorrow and then no show
Friday we're finally taking those summer
fridays we were all talking about forces
yeah I wouldn't be here anyway cuz
Myanmar go fly back in from Raleigh on
Tuesday I mean on Friday morning um and
you guys take a break we take a break
you guys take the day off homesick [ __ ]
that [ __ ] no totally and like all summer
we've been talking about these summer
fridays that we're gonna happen for us
and they just never happened cuz we've
been serving up premium content so we're
taking the day but we finally do have
two exciting weeks because after this
week Jackie is gone for the entire week
right yeah and Monday and Tuesday I have
Taylor's trucker co-hosting who was very
demanded by all because it's we haven't
caught up with her since the toast you
know and she's just such a great co-host
and I think that we needed two days
together because she's just a great host
and offers great insight into the past
five but she's also a guest and people
want to know like what happened and I
really just want to talk to her cuz I
love her
Wednesday backed by Belgium and been
again let us know if you get sick of
them okay I'm just excited for you and
then Ben is a great co-host like for me
as fulfilling the hosting duties but it
has a married couple like that's a
flavor we haven't seen before on the
show room and
maybe we'll fight or something maybe
you'll renew your vows where my bail
Margot get ordained go to ordained calm
and then are renewing their vows live on
the toe and common week that's such a
cute idea yeah that's nice but even
though it's occurs it's a curse because
everyone on the real housewives who
renews their vows gets divorced Mario
and Ramona Vicki and Donn but that's why
you have to renew your vows not it's
like a last chance but as like when
things are good wait actually me and
Ben's one-year anniversary is coming up
should we save it for that and do like a
whole spot no no you know what let's
just ooh it
yeah like cuz you have to do you have to
do the renewal of the vows like when
things are good cuz then it's not a
curse and it's just like a fun thing
that you're doing and then Thursday we
have the points guy Brian Kelly coming
as a guest and a host I'm really excited
for people to get to know him like on a
deeper level because yes he runs
literally the most successful company
ever and he's like so smart but he's
also just like the funnest coolest
fun-loving guy and I just can't befriend
one to see both sides we had dinner last
night we were just like you know talking
strategy oh yeah yeah thanks a good time
and then another summer Friday because
we learned and then another summer
Friday because Thursday night I'm doing
two shows and Hasmik writes New Jersey
first one sold out so we added a second
one segments almost sold out so make
sure to get your tickets at girls no job
comm and then I'm driving back I just
know I'll be tired like I wouldn't be
able to give it my all after two shows
and then driving back so but luckily
it's Friday and it's summer so it's a
summer Friday and in the words of my my
inspiration Rebecca Black you got to get
down on Friday you just gotta you really
do also in the words of my inspiration
something that's really just thanks your
inspiration my inspiration today is
Margo shirt
States don't worry be monkey what you
know is so profound and deeply
insightful that I don't know how Zahra
came up with it know like this is my
favorite shirt of Marcus and I know she
hates wearing it because I never I guess
never tell her talking it's honestly
lame as [ __ ]
it makes no [ __ ] sense don't worry be
monkey right like monkeys eat bananas
like are you telling me to go on a diet
I don't know I really don't know also
let's put this debate to rest
Zehra Zehra Zehra Zehra Zehra well we're
just obnoxious and we say well is it an
American company because if it's an
American come it's not no it's British
mmm
trying to think it's ara it is are for
them and it Sarah for us like you know a
so what is it ASOS
no no it's a cross no people say it's a
sews no no no adidas sorry
Adi this is a UK company and it's really
pronounced adios no it's yes it is yes
it is yes it is all day I dream about
sports you mean yes exactly
also I'm sipping on öland spring our
official sponsor I love me some old and
spring when I'm not worrying and being
monkey monkeys need water too
that's my motto for the day if anyone
sees me worrying just let me know don't
worry B monkey also me and talk here
both watching on YouTube today cuz the
comment tests favor so let and I was
really pleased B monkey don't be all
like a monkey are you gonna be okay with
this is [ __ ] sharp he shakes me crazy
Margo we have to have a ceremonial
burning of the shirt I'm sorry okay okay
with that no I can't
we wanted this church and no honestly
when we get to a clubhouse level of our
set we need to frame the shirt I'm
hanging on the wall we need like a
toaster we need we have Stevens email
from summer house yeah we need those old
letters we used to use the J and the C
it's so sad from Amazon I'm what else do
we need to put up there oh I get so many
gifts from eating greens for us like I
got this big stuffed animal toast we
need to get a pillow by Craig from yeah
charm by the way did you see Andy
Cartman's Instagram stories yesterday
all about toes I did people think he's
some lemon they talking to us and as
much as I want to believe it he's on
here's the thing he's not for sure like
I can tell you that he's not but let's
just pretend that he isn't it's fun and
bright flare
I forget that like toast is also a piece
of bread because now it's just solely
the number one Morning Show in the
entire world right but he's talking
toasts toasters like all forms of toasts
no it's definitely subliminal yeah the
time the timing is weird it's a little
fishy and maybe if we all bombarded him
on Instagram or riding him on the
morning toast that would help like
nobody did that yesterday I'm back of
couse Instagram it did then I got a
bunch of stuff she posted like right
after our show yeah and that was like
really [ __ ] us up I understand
hopefully she got the message I feel
like she's in tune yeah no she
definitely gives off the vibe of being
in tune with what's necessary definitely
well without further ado we are going to
not worry be monkey and hit you with the
fast five stories that
need to know before you wake up and take
a plate morning no show okay what's up
what's up hey jets and then go on the
world in the past 24 hours um you know a
few things actually we have another
wealth of knowledge for you today of
course but as per usual well throw well
because they both make sense because
like a well is full of water and you
need it like to live like you need the
knowledge each I'd like a well full of
knowledge but you could also have like a
rich in knowledge yeah I'm curious well
today we have a wealth of knowledge
are you um per usual we're gonna start
with celebrity news before we get to the
really hard-hitting stories that are
really taking the world by storm
clearly by stormy Webster first up
Taylor Swift fights back tears at her
concert on the anniversary of sexual
assault trial verdict for Taylor Swift
August 14th will always be a bittersweet
day while on stage in tampon Tuesday as
part of her tour Swift nearly broke down
in tears as she opened up about her 2017
groping trial quote a year ago I was not
playing in the stadium in Tampa I was in
a courtroom in Denver Colorado she
bravely began this is the day the jury
sided in my favor and said that they
believed me I guess I just think about
all the people that weren't believed and
the people who haven't been believed in
the people who are afraid to speak up
because they think they won't be
believed I just wanted to say I'm sorry
to anyone who ever wasn't believed
because I don't know what turn my life
would have taken if someone didn't
believe me when I said something
happened to me so I just wanted to say
we have so much further to go and I'm so
grateful to you guys for being there for
me for what was really a horrible part
of my life I wanted to thank you for
just kind of I mean I know when I meet
you guys at meet and greets and after
the shows you guys tell me about the
hard times that you've gone through in
your lives and I really appreciate you
trusting me with that information and
you know you guys have seen me go
through so many ups and downs in my life
just due to the public nature of the way
my life is and I just wanted to say that
I'm so happy to see you and to have you
and know you through the ups and downs
in my life I love her so much
honestly that whole trial gives me such
a big pit because like when they were
like cross-examining her and she was
being like so the lawyer was being like
such a little [ __ ]
and then when Kesha went through her
thing and Taylor was like one of the
only people who literally gave her money
like yes everyone like stands by ketchup
like Kesha was going through a million
dollar lawsuit and had absolutely no
income and she's still fighting dr. Luke
and dr. Lucas
working to catch the thing like really
so unjust like I just don't understand
how that's still happening in 28 I'm
Taylor strip was literally the only
person who put her mind I think maybe
Lady gaga actually I don't want to
misspeak but she was one of the only
people who like literally put her money
where her mouth is like literally she
gave her 250 grand to pay her lawyers
like Taylor Swift is an icon I'm sorry
everything she does makes me love her
even more and now I'm even more
justified in making my Instagram account
swifty with no job how's that going it's
you know what it's really a passion
project like it's not growing in
followers so fast and I couldn't care
less like I'm really doing it because
like on the regular like I'm scrolling
my explore page and I just like watch
videos of her singing from like random
award shows like I really enjoy it and
then just to be like to curate my own
feed of like Taylor moments is like I
love doing it that's great it's a
passion project that's a fun hobby
I know people need more hobbies I'm
really big on hobbies easy what are your
hobbies
do not say SoulCycle no I wasn't gonna
cry oh um what are my hobbies well right
now I have like things that I have to do
that I have to make my hobbies so like
for a while like during my apartment
that is a hobby and right now decorating
planning my wedding is my hobby not a
fun hobby like my real hobbies my real
joys in life like I know you're gonna
make fun of me makeup it's makeup like
you sitting down at my vanity and just
like doing my painting painting my face
like painting pillows I could do that
like for fun even if I'm not going to
get where I know you mean I'm just like
watching makeup videos or like going
shopping for makeup or talking about
makeup talking with other people about
makeup like that just like gets that
gets the people going um I used to knit
like and not very well and like I didn't
really make anything except like a scarf
literally for a doll but it was just
like fun to like have something to do
with your hands and like you're not on
your phone and like you would just be
watching TV and I feel like I can't
watch TV anymore like I don't I'm not
present yeah when you guys made me watch
that movie wild child on Netflix where
you were like you can't be on your phone
during this movie like that was hard for
me but like it was enjoyable do you know
what he means yeah I really need to do
things to occupy my hands like that over
at my phone I agree I need to like
consciously put your phone away
sometimes it can be so taxing you should
get one of those like kits I used to
make pot holders at camp they're like
really easy to make and it's just like a
nice activity for your hands we should
we're straight yeah like from the app
will do it in Camtasia it makes it we're
all making friendship bracelets I can
tell I've been getting so many
about people from like camp tous we're
just like so excited to be there like I
got the sweetest email this woman's like
my daughter went to camp and like I was
so jealous like I just bought a ticket
I'm like yes Rene and I've been seeing
toasters who are like asking if other
toasters are going alone and a lot of
people are going alone and the bunking
is gonna be if there's a toaster you
have in mind who haven't Maddie you want
to bunk with you can request them and if
not we'll do your bunk space I'm like
interest and where you're from so that
if you make lifelong friendships you
don't see each other you can see you
have to travel cross-country like Annie
and Hallie did in The Parent Trap right
and then you'll just live ten months for
two wait Jackie I got such a good
question on my bath time Q&A that I was
like really thinking about like are you
more of a Hallie Parker or a nanny and I
really feel like you're an Amy and I'm
the Hallie I agree and we should really
lean into that for camp toast I'm in the
words of Cheryl whatever her name is
Lena no who's never lean in thing
Sandberg Sandberg hey Sam it's mom
I'm definitely a nanny yeah you are you
love it you like look the part
yeah especially today in your blase but
I'm much more of like chill California
girl on the vineyard and like I read
stir your back and that songs bad to the
bone dan Anna man and I would really the
only mistake I think how they made us I
would befriend Meredith Blake because
honestly like her parents getting back
together it's like a movie ending that
doesn't happen in real life so I'd make
the best like Meredith Blake was like a
big-time publicist she could have gotten
you a ton of Instagram followers I agree
but not only like their parents getting
back together was a sweet thing but she
use her sis and also it's really [ __ ]
up that they separated those kids I
think that documentary
three identical strangers and it's so
it's about a social experiments a
horrible horrible story and I refused to
see the movie too because I we know how
it ends cuz it's a true story and that's
also like the plot of Parent Trap and
it's underrated Lee [ __ ] up as [ __ ]
that is so true nobody talks about the
moral dilemma that is the Parent Trap
separating twins is like first of all
twins are like so inextricably like
linked emotionally that like them being
away from each other they can feel
something missing and them not knowing
that they are sibling is even more
confusing as like a young prepubescent
yeah like you were in utero together and
like those feelings don't just go away
wait that's so crazy no one talks about
that but in humanity the inhumanity like
this social experiment that like really
[ __ ] up social experimenters did
honestly isolation Kevin
isolated happen for that and there will
basically should happen at camp to
isolation happen this thing will like
never not be one of my favorite
references because everyone knows it and
it wasn't even that iconic in the movie
it was just like why did she do that but
because she got like one line oh and you
know you don't know this but the woman
who did that is Janice friends written
to you and that was like the only role
she's had outside of friends and she's
on something now but like it's just when
when you have a role like that you can't
be you can't play that's like Fran
Drescher pink playing something anything
other than the nanny
really yes like she's that main of how
she wasn't mean
she appeared probably once a season and
at her coming back was always a joke
they're like oh I wonder who's sitting
next house and it would be Janice like
it was just like and she'd there was an
annoying voice and like she's so Janice
that her being something else was just
weird you know that is weird
someone were something really funny that
fur cam toast we have to get chassis
from the OC oh my god especially with
her to make us remember the breakfast
she made for Halle we're like Halle
didn't eat anything she had like a bite
of toast where she had literally like
pancakes waffles oh my god Annie and she
doesn't and British people don't need
breasts right that's so I went to dinner
last night with the points guy and I did
not eat the bread basket it looks so
good to go amazing restaurant um I don't
remember the name where was it what kind
of cuisine um it was like American
Italian so they had pastas but they also
had like lots of fishes oh I got salmon
and my favorite kind of restaurant you
actually you would love this restaurant
they have good salad and it's like fancy
but the decors like low-key so I wore
t-shirt that's my that's my total vibe
and I was so weird yes sir like I
literally like left the house and like
jeans and a t-shirt like this is like a
short sleeve blouse like a t-shirt like
it was actually like one of Ben's like
it's a like cheap trick on it like I
just felt like such a girl like a
regular girl you know it's always that
weird feeling to a routine sanity yeah
and I feel like effortless beautiful
girls like always waiting jeans and a
t-shirt it's like not a big deal that's
off duty a big behemoth like me wearing
him jeans at a tea it's like
revolutionary how did it feel um I was
really comfortable and my jeans are
sitting so much better these days ever
since I'd literally stopped even like a
hyena and like I just I feel great I'm
happy thank thank you that's a great
feeling it is it's not the whole like
being hungry thing but no but but it pay
at least there's like rewards also you
know what the reward is I've been
drinking so much water
and my skin is so much better like I was
going through a rough patch with my skin
in terms of like dryness and just like
random pimples and I still get pimples
up in my hairline it's like when you
sweat like you that's unavoidable but
I've just been looking in the mirror and
being like a damn girl you got good skin
are you going waterworks I literally I'm
gonna foul me why'd you say waterworks
and I do this whole bit in my show that
I'm gonna contradict but waterworks Wow
you guys I mercury is in retrograde for
confirmed and now it's double confirmed
look at my nails mercury is in
retrograde like have you ever not good
no not good okay next story is really
sad but reality star lyric McHenry was
found dead at the age of 26 ship reality
star lyric McHenry was found dead after
an East Coast birthday celebration New
York City police confirm a 26 year old
female was found above the major Deegan
Expressway early Tuesday morning the
victim was transported to Bronx Lebanon
Hospital where she was pronounced dead
police say there were no obvious signs
of trauma in several instable instagram
stories posted late Monday evening
Larrick documented her night out in the
Big Apple she tagged herself at the
Frederick Hotel the Soho grand hotel and
the dream downtown in addition the
reality star posted video of herself
snapping selfies in the bathroom and
mingling with friends who wish her a
happy birthday so she is from AJ
Johnson's reality show EJ NYC she was on
the series and then she was also a
producer and he was one of the many
friends to wish her happy birthday
earlier in the month like they're really
good friends so like this is really sad
and Margo said was she pregnant pregnant
yeah that's what the initial I don't
know honey months pregnant Margo we said
months I don't know he didn't report
that but in the initial story that I
read which I had saw on Twitter that she
was pregnant too but how did she die she
was just found dead apparently wearing
like a pajama top and underwear like in
this leg no that's so sad
highway look I'm a major Deegan that's
like such a random place that's and this
like in New Jersey no it's not it's all
the way up in the Bronx it's like on
your way to New Jersey yeah if you want
to get to New Jersey you got to take the
major Deegan and when they read it on
the traffic signs they spell at the maj
Deegan I'm like the majhergaon you know
this story right what oh my god we were
in the car when we were like not kids
actually like teenagers and we were on
the highway and I was with Olivia and
Finn so I'm in the backseat I like
explaining his somewhat we were going to
someone in New Jersey I was explaining
where we were and I was like run the
miles she's on they were like they were
like what are you want and Olivia and
Vince like turn around they're like what
did you say I was like the mazi jaan
because it's Maj period like they but
it's not a major such a long word it's
literally two more letters MH a de GaN
though de now it says de but for what it
was de GaN okay like it's the monster
shot and they were [ __ ] shucks and
then I like learned that day I was like
oh it's not what I thought it was when
something so different and then a few
months later doing the same trip I was
but I was with Olivia and someone else
Olivia can attest to this story and I
was like we were on it again and I was
like oh I'm sorry it's the maize Dijon
like I still couldn't get it
no we have such a weird highway like the
name is so weird the major Deegan like
it literally sounds like we're below the
mason-dixon all that means you're being
it mazi jaan it's the major Deegan
it's so insane but I really feel badly
for spelling it out cuz I said nah she's
on again wait this is like so sad and
when people just like show up
mysteriously it's like what the hell
happened it's crazy that's so much [ __ ]
happens in the world and like only God
knows you know mm-hmm Hamid I know but
God and the person who did it like
somebody else knows yeah no I just like
when when mysteries go unsolved or like
things are like creepy and weird like I
get so freaked out like there's so much
that like only God knows no I totally
agree Oh crazy I wonder if we got
answers like you know in afterlife yeah
I feel like we do right like what's
what's with the I feel like we don't get
answers now Chaminade like Japanese
parents do you know yeah okay right
because it's like we're not we're not
entitled like to that sort of
information that's a good point
you know anyways next story in news that
should have happened years ago Thomas
Ravenel quit southern charm and says the
show took advantage of me amid sexual
assault claims Thomas Ravenel took to
Twitter ugly story he said on Twitter
quote I'm not doing the show anymore in
the contract they have the right to
fictionalize her story they took
advantage of me I decided I've got too
much to lose and informed them I'm not
coming back he's right they did
fictionalize his story because for six
seasons it seemed like he was a good guy
him look like
and they made Catherine look crazy so
you're right they did they did change
your story by the way he definitely
thought he was like blowing up Bravo
spot by saying like your contract like
[ __ ] we know everything's fake we watch
it all through that lens like please he
thought he was like blowing it up like
look at this major information like it's
it's not real like oh wow it's not
usually when things are at the court
level and things are public access
documents like there's only so much that
Bravo can fabricate right there's only
so much that isn't true from a legal
standpoint right um I will not be
missing Thomas Ravenel I'm so here for
the era of Kathryn Dennis Calhoun
Calhoun Dennis excuse me I'm ready for
just like I'm ready for a fresh start
for her and she can't have that it's
like her full-time job is working with
Thomas I agree and there's a new wish
that Thomas liked was the reunion
there's a reckoning or like had to show
up to one party season opener and
everyone looking at him like you
disgusting yeah no it's like it's unfair
I don't need him in the new season I
needed him at the Reunion him not having
to answer for any of the garbage he did
to Katherine any of the assault claims
and him just being like a terrible
person like that's unfair I agree also I
don't know how you feel about this but
everyone like posting back and forth
about Ashley Jacobs in her Instagram
Bogatyr
deleting pictures I'm officially try
knowing her from this show until
something actual happen Jacobs from the
group actually every time she posts
something I don't want to see it in the
toasters you guys so Ashley Jacobs
you've been Chyna
we have a lot of a viewer that did feel
really good we've a lot of new viewers
these days so if you guys don't know
what China it is it's an old school term
that we invented just added to the
laundry list of things we invented when
we're done talking about someone and it
started with blac Chyna like when she
was showing her bagina before noon to
rob like there was just so much going on
there is another story about her more
like we just can't talk about Sony we're
getting rid of her we're China inge her
and now we just use it for people we're
China like people we don't want to talk
about anymore people we've exhausted
talking about Nick vile he's been China
yeah who else I think we China
Chloe Anderson the scandal the story not
the people not the people actually I'm
like I think I'm pretty much trying to
Tristan like I'm done with him right
just anyone you're like just done with
you can feel free to use that term in
everyday life someone who like the horse
has been beaten you know we're done
beating a dead horse yeah they need
horses don't they what's what they shoot
horses issue yeah another book I didn't
read in school a lot of people were
upset with us
for not promoting reading and I please
say my ass grab I don't feel back is
enough people promote reading there's
only two people in this word we're
telling you not to read no they don't
have to read but like don't feel
pressure to read you know I can go into
this again I got like so worked up
yesterday no but I feel like there are
enough good influences telling you to
read so like go to Goodreads calm right
okay this next story is so crazy news
that came out this morning that like
isn't really what we typically talk
about but I just find it to be like so
sad and wild I'm this that stories are
like so sad I know but it they happen
they do and we can't ignore them
shocking photo shows a Genoa bridge
crumbling and caving in just a few weeks
before it collapsed killing at least 39
people holy [ __ ] so at least 39 people
are dead after a huge section of Morandi
bridge suddenly collapsed during a
fierce storm in Genoa Italy new photos
taking just weeks before the tragedy
shows it crumbling with wires hanging
from its sides
cars and trucks fell 115 150 feet at
11:30 a.m. as one witness described the
carnage as an apocalyptic scene the
bridge was built on the 1/10 ol motorway
in northwestern Italy in the 1960s and
was undergoing repairs Engineers said
the 50-year old bridge was felled by
structural issues and not by wind or
lightening the bridge likely had a fatal
construction flaw or wear and tear
corrosion issues that were missed and
expensive you know what I'm hearing no
I'm hearing s what I'm hearing hey says
what are you hearing human error
like this could have been avoided
avoided like if the bridge had been
struck by lightning and mother nature
took it down like that's just
unfortunate circumstance but by the way
who does construction on a bridge while
it's still being used like that's weird
that's weird also the pictures from the
bridge of the weeks before there's wires
hanging like jay-z did not look safe and
like it doesn't take an engineer to see
that there's something wrong with the
bridge like hold your breath when you go
over a bridge I do I look freaked out
like the 59 shaper I just coming down
you got it's like it is so JK's is it oh
my god it's so jinking there's a cords
around like people are walking on it the
psychos who walk across the Brooklyn
Bridge are just like asking for it like
are you kidding how I'm gonna have a
fear of bridges no bridges are so stupid
like we take the tunnel I like the
tunnel I you sick then it's out by the
time when I'm in the tunnel I'm like
we're technically underwater if there's
like a small hole it just like starts
in the wheel dock yeah you can't think
about where you're right honestly yeah
you just have to like cross your fingers
hope for the best
this is a horrible horrible story we
have some pictures that we're posting to
the stream of the bridge when I when I
was in high school there was okay let me
try and remember the right verbiage in
my physics class you wouldn't know we
were learning no we were learning about
this thing called natural frequency
where it's like every odd object on
earth has like a natural frequency that
if it reaches like it just collapses
like and it's so rare it's like so crazy
and this bridge like years ago reached
its natural frequency like the wind got
to this frequency and it literally just
collapsed no and do you see there's one
bridge that like reached its frequency
the resonance is missing and oh
definitely the bridge the force yeah I
thought it was the natural frequency
it's a resonance I'm pretty sure it's
not a frequency the bridge shaking yes
oh yes okay you're right little bridge
resonance shaking it's so freaky and
then you'll never get out in another
bridge no I'm done with bridges like I
mean there's so many bridges in the city
we have the Triborough which has been
weirdly renames the RFK which is like if
you live in New York you know what the
tremor is but even if you don't live in
New York it was the most genius name for
it connects three boroughs so it's the
Triborough bridge they randomly you
can't rename a bridge people have been
on forever like who do you think you are
and by the way nobody calls it that like
no we're not cotton Inc to their to
their names you there are FK yeah like
what like a taxi driver would they're
like how do you want to get there they
like the Triborough yeah like nobody's
calling it the RFK you can't just rename
a bridge that would be like renaming the
Majda job so much highway talk today I
know wait you know when I think of the
highways by the way we've never spoken
about highways and here we are opening
up new pockets
totally when I think of the highway did
you know they think about the highway
well it is but know what weirdly I think
of um David beador cuz that's the work
that he does and he was always getting
up early that's why they were sleeping
in different beds and he was getting up
early cause he's like highway before
like highway construction like before
people got up well they should have sent
him to Genoa because the people who are
responsible for this so I'm like and you
know what's annoying like if this was
like like our fault like we would be
brought to justice but like when it's
the government's fault it's just like oh
it's the blame game and then
just you know nurse to jail for this
they'll circle-jerk each other until we
forget but honestly this is the sort of
[ __ ] that like I'm not gonna forget like
now every time I take a bridge like I'm
gonna think of Genoa and also like using
public transportation just requires so
much faith in the government like even
highways that aren't even that tall as
tall as a bridge like you're just
trusting trusting the fact that those
nineteen hundred's workers that PT
Barnum when he went to go build the
railroad didn't [ __ ] up totally such a
good call you know we put so much trust
just like every time I get into a car
I'm trusting that every car around me
isn't just gonna like Ram themselves
into me
we're like blindly trusting people we
don't know
cab drivers or we're drivers that could
kill us yeah well that's a whole lot
that's just yeah that's a whole other
thing but no even if they're not
intending to kill you like just human
error like literally a 12 year old built
the railroads in the 1800s totally and
he was hungry PT Barnum he didn't even
have strength right he couldn't even he
was selling newspapers out of the trash
if only he had the supreme cover he
would have made a big toad I forget one
no and I said I didn't follow up on it
but we're seeing greatest showmen
tonight and I'm so excited it's at Pier
17 outdoors and it's gonna be the first
time in a while I'd watch it from front
to back and I'm gonna turn my phone off
because I'm I want to just and that's
like a huge speed theater screen
experience right and that's how you have
to see greatest showman ever you on a
plane I'm I love watching it on the
plane I'm sorry I accept me embargo
looked up our flight to Raleigh and
there's no um TVs so I had to download
the 1989 World Tour which I'll be ok you
she had an iPad by the way I've been
thinking more and more about getting an
iPad I think that you really should
especially for all your travel it's one
it's best for me cuz it's bigger than an
airplane TV you download whatever you
want beforehand but and then you have
this library the only thing is that I
would still bring my computer because
I'm a workaholic these days but I pads
not heavy no but like for writing emails
no I bring my iPad at my computer when I
travel okay what's the point we use my
computer on the plane I did I just think
it makes a difference like this iPad you
can use prop up anywhere well I was
thinking when you're gone like what am I
to do for this stories I'll have to get
a tablet a Windows Marga do tell me dear
toasters yeah I did okay good she's such
a good snitch turn we have 800 emails I
don't I don't really know what like I
sent it to one that
oh okay you oh I hope yeah I know did
you make them good yeah well-rounded
well-rounded okay show first to that I
send you there at the bottom they're
very similar and not very necessary okay
sounds like I mean we state your kinky
sister I know thank you sister
thank you sister also what's crazy about
this story is right now there's no video
of the bridge collapsing and Daily Mail
is like out here being like if you were
there email Chris that's ten times it's
like enough like when the paparazzi were
taking pictures of Bethany at Genesis
funeral like stop that was inhumane
because not only is Dennis not a
celebrity his family is not famous like
they didn't deserve that and those
pictures of Bethany like it's such an
intimate like sad moment like I refuse I
was gonna look people are sending them
to me like to post on them Towson's now
I just I'm like I would never like that
is such a line I do not cross invasion
of privacy and by the way he was a
public figure like pictures out of
funeral like how violent but now they
give like when other famous people have
died like I didn't see any pictures from
like Joan Rivers funeral yeah I think
you saw some pictures outside the few no
but the outside yes but not at the
burial no like same with Bobbie like
there were cameras no one there were
robbing in film inside there were no
cameras inside just outside on the
street which is like public whatever and
those were not as bad like then
literally burying Dennis like that was
so invasive I literally couldn't believe
that people were sharing it on Instagram
I was not gonna contribute to the
cesspool that is the paparazzi like
where do we draw the line as a community
we don't think those are paparazzi
pictures yes full paparazzi because I
think they were really far away and zoom
done which only like a paparazzi camera
could do horrible and if you're a person
visiting someone at a cemetery and you
see Stephanie and you take a picture of
her Atteberry oh like you're the devil I
don't think people like that exist I
don't know you never know people
continue to surprise me in ways that
they can be evil agreed are you ready
for our fifth and final story which is
actually some fun exciting news we
breathe right through those sure you
really did cuz be able like to get you
today there's a new Girl Scout cookie
coming out next year and it sounds
delicious Girl Scout cookie season is
one of the best times of the year with
Scouts finding creative ways to sell
cookies and even celebrity moms like
Jennifer Garner joining in on the
excitement but in 2019 cookie fans will
have yet another reason to celebrate for
the first time since the year the
s'mores cookie joined the family cookie
lovers will have a new option to add to
their orders of thin mints and Samoas
caramel chocolate chip cookies
starting January 2nd
official start of the Girl Scout cookie
selling season didn't know that the new
treat will be available in select areas
across the country the chewy chip
cookies made with caramel semi-sweet
chocolate chips and boasts a hint of sea
salt in every bite oh he is also
gluten-free making it the second
gluten-free option in the collection
following the return of toffee tastic so
close so close
you almost but I guess like kids easy
break allergies everyone's a celiac also
why mess with perfection when it comes
to Girl Scouts you know so weird like
Girl Scouts is like like this big thing
no I never experienced no we were not
Girl Scouts growing up I never even
heard of someone who was a Girl Scout
apparently it's just like national thing
meanwhile I didn't know anyone growing
up who was a Girl Scout but a lot of the
people who signed up for camp toast when
they were like writing notes in the
group they're like I went to Girl Scout
camp I was a Girl Scout my whole life
and like I literally want to go back to
girls hair camp than adult but I think
that's weird so I just go to can't just
so maybe our version of Girl Scouts was
like when we went to camp but also I
feel like Girl Scouts just isn't a very
Jewish thing right that's I was gonna
say that it's like we just supplemented
it with camp right I don't know I feel
like definitely setting my daughter to a
girl scout would be like a good thing
for them if they could learn good values
at Girl Scouts good values good skills
to have like how to start a fire yeah
they're very well well-run company I've
never heard of any drama with the Girl
Scouts now someone's gonna like bring it
up to me but most part I think they're
untouched and I feel like it there could
like I could I could imagine things that
could happen there but it seems pretty
kosher okay but like when someone
started Girl Scouts like what was the
idea like hey let's get a bunch of kids
together and give them patches like well
okay impetus I'm gonna I'm gonna go out
on a limb I'm gonna say it started with
Boy Scouts as all things Oh true they
just wanna be a man teach them how to be
a man yeah yeah yeah rub some dirt in it
exactly I gotta start a fire you know
congregate with other boys and then the
girls were like we can do this too and
then they made Girl Scouts make me
better cookies and now Girl Scouts are
taking over and Boy Scouts can grab a
spoon
totally also I want to talk about thin
mints because I've actually never had
like Girl Scout bread did did mints but
I've had like a thin mint cookie before
and I want to say that Girl Scout
branded thin mint I don't think so where
do you get that I'll tell you how I've
had them uh if you work in a corporate
office someone with kids is always
bringing in their kids Girl Scout
cookies
and selling them yeah where does the
money go to fund Girl Scouts I believe
Girl Scouts like a non-profit I don't
know it seems like a boys and girls club
like I took it just today after school
program for like good kids right and
that requires funding right so like
where do they produce these cookies like
they factory money true also like that
movie the boss
yes yes and that other movie um the Wes
Anderson movie that was absolutely
terrible moon right moonlight river
shine yeah moonshine mmm Margo look it
up what's Anderson Girl Scout movie moon
moonrise kingdom
honestly I'm about to see something
controversial like Wes Anderson's movies
suck like whoever like the the message
he's trying to convey I don't get it
I am NOT the target audience for a bus
interesting maybe I want a movie that is
obviously funny like the joke is not
like hard or like the message isn't like
difficult to understand like I that
other movie um no that's only what I've
seen random hotel I did I rented it once
and I literally turn it on for a minute
I was like I can't do this he's choking
me wrong I'm not saying these movies are
bad like they're just not free they're
very specific and like they're art films
but they're mainstream like accepted art
films and I don't get it
have you ever seen Royal Tenenbaums oh
no but I know Margo so if you if you
were ever to like a Wes Anderson movie
it would be that one that was good but
the modern they once they just like look
pretty and I like the posters but yeah
I'm with you sis moonrise kingdom that
was a movie that was not made for me and
I understand I cannot everything is for
me really the kids are in the tent like
touching each other and like I didn't
get him home ya know I didn't get and
the parents were like fighting at home
like your kids running away like that it
will not be a toaster movie of the week
no no but maybe rural town miles away
yeah just cuz I want you to see it just
it we might not like it but I just want
to hear your thoughts what was the story
what was a great house yeah oh so my
thought was gonna say like yes they're
very good but have you ever had snack
wells dev like their version of the Thin
Mint it's like it's a fat mint
yeah the Figment yes they're like big
fluffy thin mints and they have like
dough cookie in them like they're so
good you guys snack Wells are everything
oh my god underrated I can't yes how'd
you get called they actually have them
when we were there no I know and we need
to double up on the order so when we
were in camp they used to get the what
are they
all devil's food know the vanilla no no
the other ones oh yes the brown line set
their own Kenny Google's snack Wells
Devil's double pink know something
devilment
oh you're slow typer yeah Wow devil's
food cookies food we should dip them in
peanut butter and it was so good those
cookies are like the fat version of Thin
Mints like the figments they're
delicious and thank you for putting a
spotlight on snack Wells everything
snack Wells makes is amazing who owns
snag Wells these are the Pillsbury brand
what is it Nabisco I think it's it's own
thing can you google that two cents I
would like to take a trip to the factory
and like dip my head and like the cream
filling that goes into the snack Wells
nature foods company stay on I'm on it
go to Wikipedia subsidiaries it's just
such a premium brand anyone you know
what they say you put things in the
universe if any of the toasters work for
snack Wells I would very much like a big
shipment of all the cookies and I feel
like they were like a brand very popular
when we were kids and now they're like a
novelty item but I want to bring them
back into the mainstream I totally agree
walking into
there was one deli by one events old
apartments it was like I don't even know
what it was it was like a halal deli and
they sold snack Wells when I worked at
iHeartRadio they had a snack section and
and they had snack Wells the vanilla
cookie with the vanilla cookie one
sandwiches which are my favorite snack
me too and then would always be like I
wouldn't have them every day because I
was like trying to be good yeah but it
would always be how I treated myself but
now if you go into a store and you get
like the little mini packs I often find
that they're sale right because they've
been there they're not together I mean I
like a big one at this hotel you go buy
like a box like give it back to your
family Wow
yeah I like the many packages personally
I know where we need to go economy candy
have you heard of it it's on the Lower
East Side it's literally like it's a
garage and you look over the door and
it's like the biggest candy store in the
world and they have like old school
candies like if you're looking for an
old candy they have it there like sky
bars remember sky bars from camp
they have like every old-school candy
and that you like remember from your
childhood that's no longer made they
have it it's literally like heaven well
when we go up to camp toast American
candle
oh that's also a great candy so they
have sky bars there they have everything
there and it's like you fill up a bag
and it's $1 per pound of candy
it's insane and they sell a lot of
candles too but if you're coming to camp
toast you gotta stop there on your right
honestly like the bus there the trick
totally the trip up to camp
host is like a fat person stream they
have just like the most worst place to
put a fat can totally because when we
were counselors you were able to leave
once a day and then every other night
and there is this place called GU bells
which is just like it literally it's
like a hut on the side of the road and
you go over and it's this ice-cream
place and they have tildes day I've
never had a birthday cake ice cream
quite as good it's vanilla ice cream
mixed with chunks of like funfetti cake
and sprinkles it's so good and they also
have a frozen yogurt place like theirs
they also have a place called I Boris
it's a coffee place but it's actually a
garage and you can pull up and it's this
big and it's the most delicious iced
coffee every flavor everything and it
comes it's the original guzzler it comes
this big and you drink the whole thing
and it's took a leader and you can get
like sugar-free flavors of everything so
it's like not even fattening and it's
the best coffee in the world I agree
mark snitchin ivory Olivia I don't even
drink coffee but I'll drink that yeah
it's the best coffee in the world it's
me I have two locations I think so if
you're driving up to kam toast like take
some time to explore your surroundings
it's just that one road I don't know the
name but wherever now bors is like on
your right there's nine bars left as
well sure it's the main street has to
take that road to get to the camp anyway
and then there's also the outlets if
you're looking to do a little shopping
oh yeah such like it's actually like a
flourishing area where you go to create
real flogging and oh and there's also a
casino man are you yeah we got we got to
spend some time then we're going up a
couple days early to like explore the
campgrounds right to make sure
everything's all settled yeah I'm also
setting up my bunk like I'm bringing
legit like a feather bed and like a
queen-size down naturally today we have
to figure out where we're bunking yeah
we're bunk together shot top bunk
it's all yours just kidding I have a
fear of heights anyways speaking of
prestigious brands the founder okay so
this week's toasts movie of the week
which is something we started about two
weeks ago where we just want to expand
our minds expand our palates we want to
watch movies we don't normally watch
like I've seen Mean Girls a hundred
times I've seen coolest hundred times
I've seen Legally Blonde hundred times
but sometimes it's like interesting to
watch an interesting movie yes a true
interesting movie or even a natural
interesting movie and something that's
just gonna make you think and put your
mind like talking about highway he's
like yeah give your mind something fresh
to think about other than your own [ __ ]
so this week's was the founder starring
Michael
Keeton Keeton he plays Ray Kroc and it
is the story of how the brand McDonald's
came to be like the multi-billion dollar
franchise that it is today and the movie
can be summed up in one word and it's
just pit pit it's called unfairness is
called cheaters always win that's the
moral of this story because like on the
one hand people are saying rayker like
yes Ray Kroc was a piece of [ __ ] but he
was a smart businessman and I actually
do not agree he was not a smart missus
man any good idea he ever had was stolen
from somewhere else
BJ Novak was the hero right even like
what actually made him all the money is
the fact that he started investing in
the in the land of the Macdonald source
when he became like oh Lamech said like
he's investing in real estate not in
burgers and but that wasn't even his
idea it's like he was just the ultimate
fraud but if cheaters always prosper
that was the moral of the story for me I
got the biggest pit at the end when like
his billionaire his billion I can't
speak English where like when he died he
like didn't even give his money to his
family no and there was like a few
things that oh and just just for Laura
Linney whatever her name is
Laura Dern the love wife who sat at home
every night while he was telling those
stupid Nikes while he was being a loser
he was such a loser but it was making me
like long for like a McDonald's I was
like glam and like a spot for people to
hang out now it's a dirty like scary
right it's not what it once was but
that's what happens when you tarnish the
brand yeah but like and even though he's
moving a colossal piece of [ __ ] like
there were a few things that he could
have done just like I don't know sleep
well at night think he might be going to
heaven like he could have made good on
his promise to give like one person well
so my problem with the whole movie is
like honestly I could understand
everything he did up until that moment
because yes it was like kind of [ __ ]
up but he want like when you're in
business if you got to be a shark like I
could I didn't agree with it but I could
understand it and then when he said in a
verbal agreement that he would give
those to McDonald brothers 1% of the
business for eternity and never followed
up on it that is when he completely lost
me like that was so [ __ ] up because
what he did to those brothers was so
unforgivable but compensating them was
1% of a multi-billion dollar business
it's like okay you know for sure they
could live with it and then also opening
up the McDonald's across the street it's
just like the
nail in the coffin for I'm making them
change their name when it's their
[ __ ] last name also something I
really loved about the movie is just the
random cameos Patrick Wilson who was in
our toast movie last week little
children he played the guy who owned the
restaurant yeah and then he bought a
couple franchises and Linda Cardellini
was his wife who is chutney I thought it
was real walking through the front door
who's the professional mistress yeah
she's also a mistress in Mad Men is she
yes no like the random cameos I was
living for great casting whoever did it
no it's it's just a great film it's a
crazy story and it's Pittsville
and it's an interesting story I feel
like it's not well known at how
McDonald's came to be the thing that it
is when it's so salacious that like
people should know about it you know
yeah
people love a little corporate drums and
it's like you think the mcdonald's is
owned by the mcdonalds family but it's
not right you always think let me meet
some of the last name mcdonald like are
they rich as hell no they were screwed
as hell totally one of the toasters said
like her family is actually mcdonald
like they were related to the to the
mcdonald's and the toast is literally
like a culmination of all things good
and pure and the toast is the greatest
show toast is the greatest show head to
our IG TV for the most premium video
about our comeuppance it really like it
makes the part where it's everything
everyone it's everything you ever need
with a picture from toaster meetups like
that really got to me you guys should
really watch you you might be featured
in it um now that we've driven and with
the thoughts on on the founder know just
keep in mind cheaters always prosper you
guys like so keep on Qi and if you are
in business and you want to go ahead and
just steal other people's ideas right
because people it's really working for
other people by the way it's so true
like everyone steals from us and like
whoever steals from us like II they've
so many more viewers than us right
cheaters always prosper that's the moral
of us right and we got to start cheating
climb and let's they're accusing us
anyway let's assign a new movie of the
week oh we have our life we have a whole
list which ones you want to do how can I
see the list yes it's at the bottom this
is an important decision give us a
moment you know what I want to do
something I haven't seen let's do the
preppy connection okay okay I'm so glad
that you chose that because I've seen it
and Margeaux seen the truth so she can
vouch for me this time it is an unknown
movie and I remember when it came out
one of her friends was like a producer
on it and he was like come
and I was like please yeah and then I
ended up watching it on Netflix and
didn't realize it was the movie he'd
been bothering us about and like wish
that I had when because hey that's to
the premiere but it was like all the way
up and yeah yeah it's okay it's called
the preppy connection where do we watch
it it's it's summer it's easy to find
it's on Netflix
it is a movie just about like a boarding
school I'm just gonna give you that it's
so interesting the turn like you do not
think you know you think you know what
this movies about bring up a good movie
like that I'm gonna watch it on one of
my flights I have a lot of yeah
okay so we'll we're gonna do it week by
week so next Wednesday oh you're not
here okay so let's do it for the
following Monday okay we get it a week
and a half to watch this movie it is a
fantastic movie if you've seen it
already don't spoil it for everyone it's
a really good movie I think you guys are
like it there's nobody you know in it
it's technically like an art film the
girl from Vampire Diaries which is such
a favorite movie isn't it I don't know
she's so pretty the main girl and that
should be add that to the list that's a
fun movie that people should see it's
like a wild child which is also on the
list but like that's not what we're
trying to do with the toast movie but
we're also just trying to show you
movies that you wouldn't have seen that
are great movies that you repertoire
okay so this week we got preppy
connection make sure to watch it you
have a week and a half to watch we will
recap it next week
can't wait okay are you guys ready for
some gear toasters I'm so excited to
hear what's going on in your life
they were hand-picked by Margo oh my god
okay she bought me a million okay it's
about the pasta friend with a drug
problem
dear Claudia and Jackie in the past few
months my best friend has gone through
some hard life changes her boyfriend
left turn as a result she was forced to
move out of her apartment and move back
in with her parents she works in detail
with a college degree so her parents are
hard on her to do more with her life so
she wasn't thrilled to move back in with
them I tried to do my best friend I
tried to do my best friend duty and be
supportive of her but she began to push
me away sleep around and started
partying almost every night major drugs
involved it's gotten to the point where
she's completely abandoned our
friendship even after being confronted
about it and several people have
approached me asking if she's okay
because she looks absolutely terrible
we've been best friends for almost 10
years and I thought she'd be my maid of
honor in my wedding feeling like I've
lost her as a friend is awful for me but
I'm also worried about her bad habits
she's pushed me away so what do I do it
Thanks toasters love me long time Wow
so I don't like torn about this because
like if someone doesn't want your help
you can't help them do you know what I
mean yeah and try as you may you're not
gonna get through to them until they
want help right so look is it worth
but your time energy and like sadness to
like invest in this girl if she doesn't
she's not interested in to lament the
loss of a friendship when the person you
were friends with doesn't really exist
anymore
and I'm sorry like I know this is gonna
sound really harsh but like a boyfriend
breaking up with you is like not like a
trauma like a death is trauma and
illness is trauma like so like if she
can't just like it's not the boyfriend
like right and I just have a hard time
with this because like as someone who's
went through a - major traumas in terms
of like deaths of people really close to
me like I've our time when people are
like like you know my something you know
I'm like really like I know real pain
and I know that's like not a stance I
should take because everyone's grief is
important like a boyfriend break up
break up is in grief and like having and
like not being able to pay your rent
sucks and it's like the worst feeling
but it's not something for you to start
like a tumultuous chuang addiction from
right she can't pay her rent was she had
to move out and she moved back in with
her parents cuz I guess she was living
with a boyfriend well since she's not
paying rent that's why she has money for
her drugs
um if she's living with her parents and
doing shots under their roof like my two
my two things are I have two pieces of
advice two different lanes one you just
gotta move on and let her ride this
thing out you tried to help her she
didn't accept your I can't say that but
nothing that you can do until she comes
to it herself or to tell her parents
right obviously sometimes like the worst
and best thing you can do for someone is
tell their parents yeah cuz like most
like Millennials like live in fear of
their parents like right you grew up
like your parents are in charge that's a
good call yeah like I love when
someone's like bullying someone on the
internet and then like the person I
think few celebrities have done that
they like email their parents good like
do you know that your child is being a
charl on the Internet it's important for
them to know appearance really have no
idea what goes on in their kids lives
right especially these days with like
the phones and the internet like they
have no idea like if I found out that my
child was a troll on the internet like
oh my god or embarrass that's the worst
thing I could I could find out you know
a good name through the mud that or that
there being that they are bullies at
school but it's the same thing yeah yeah
no I mean kids are inherently evil
and I'm never cease I never cease to be
amazed by the new levels the new heights
of evil kids reach like when you hear
about like kids who are like so
viciously bullied in school like by just
like you know my friend's kid like it
could you know it's a and they're
worried they were raised well it's not
like they're rain
by evil people it's like kids who have
normal lives that grow up in the suburbs
you know you know in you know of
middle-class families like they just
they have notes like strife in their
life and they turn out to be evil great
kids are crazy
it's like the movie Wonder except he was
raised by mean people I didn't see that
movie because I saw the trailer and I
just broke down like I literally was so
upset by it I couldn't watch it it's
it's so upsetting like the beginning
just like the bullying it's like oh my
god
oh my god Jacob Tremblay in room-like
Jacob Tremblay is a walking Pitt because
he always plays like a sad kid and room
was like a lot for me it took me like
almost a year to like must stop the
courage to watch I'm still having I
don't think I will ever ever ever watch
wonder like it looks so sad it's sad but
like it's happy but it tells it's just
well room is technically happy too I
didn't watch wonder now like I only
watch wonder because I wanted to go to
the movies and like sometimes I'll watch
things I wouldn't normally watch but
like once it's on like my TV no like
yeah it's an in theatre a kind of
experience yeah anyways tell her parents
dear toasters by the way if you guys
want to submit to dear toasters all you
have to do is emailed your toasters at
Gmail we're talking everything we're
talking drugs apparently we talk wedding
stuff work stuff relationship stuff
literally anything you need help with I
think we offer good advice we're
responsible advice I feel like me too
and this is the one of the few cases in
life where snitches is you should snitch
yeah oh by the way never in life should
you snitch unless it's to someone's
parents for like the better of their
their daughter or sons really like
livelihood agree next time hello you
beautiful people ready off to a good
start I believe that you have it all
figured out what could you need advice
from us from for coming out I can't seek
English today so I've been dating my
boyfriend for five years now living
together for a little over a year
everything is wonderful we're super in
love there's one weird issue my best
friend makes it seem like she's
legitimately in love with him I'm
normally thrilled when my friends get
along with him and I thought I would
feel the same to have my best friend be
so close to him but this particular
situation has been giving me a weird pit
definitely worthy of a pet yeah it's
gotten worse in the past year there's
been times where we've attended her
family functions and she's videoed her
siblings having conversations with him
because she was so excited what she
tells him he looks good whenever she
sees him and her social media makes it
look like he's her man I've asked my
boyfriend if it's just me
being crazy hormonal [ __ ] and even he
thinks it's super weird when does the
third wheel go too far do I say this
that to her that this is bothering me or
do I just let it go further
clarification this is not worth losing
her as a friend and by no means do I
think my boyfriend is going anywhere but
I do think there is a way for me to send
her some signals that she needs to ease
up a little is that selfish to want to
make her feel a little uncomfortable to
prevent it from annoying me for years to
come
okay the third wheel has gone too far I
know exactly what you're talking about
I've seen even like other couples like I
I know what I know what you're saying
and it's [ __ ] weird and there's
something weird about her and she needs
to get her own and by the way where
there smoke in a situation like this
like there's fire she's in love with him
it's not like herb just being like a
good friend
no no friend is he that good no it's
it's weird and it's creepy and I mean
personally I wouldn't say something
because I would feel like so awkward
upper doesn't change its spots like she
knows what she's doing if she's your
friend she's and you're so in tune like
you called us beautiful like she
obviously is with it too but she this
isn't all an accident so what what I
would do because I'm not confrontational
I know we're gonna say and I'm gonna say
this is that I would distance myself and
you know what maybe she'll get her own
life and then you guys can come back
together throw some but this third wheel
you got a it's a flat tire man I mean
she said she doesn't want to lose his
girl as a friend so maybe not distance
but just like stop putting this girl and
your boyfriend in the same room so much
hang out with her alone like green it's
good to have girl time you don't need
your boyfriend to be everywhere that
this girl is your boyfriend doesn't need
it to be at her family event functions
that yes you should be there you're her
friend your man can say honestly you
need to take a little responsibility too
because you're obviously have crossed a
line if your boyfriend's coming on like
her brothers bar mitts about whatever
the function was I know so like he's
he's your boyfriend so like he doesn't
have to be there like once you're
engaged like he can comment right you
like then that gives you like more of a
tether to him and she might get the
picture but yeah I would I would keep
him away you're both at fault honestly
like you're a little naive yeah but you
know no good deed no [ __ ] good deed I
never understood what that phrase meant
because it was like in home alone and
they were saying and I'm like what the
hell are you talk about with the woman
with the pigeons and then I started you
a nice things for people and it never
went my favor and then I was like really
no good deed goes no I understood it
from wicked well it's a double negative
no good
how's it go I don't know I don't even
know what that's wrong it's a song from
wicked no good deed goes unpunished and
it's really true okay but it's a double
negative no good deed goes unpunished so
it's like oh good deed goes punished
that's an easier way to understand it I
guess but that just sounds worse or you
just do a good deed one thing y'all
understand yeah help someone one time
you'll be cured this is our final one
hijacking Klaudia hopeless helpless
romantic I'm a big fan and typically
listen to the show every day at my
internship it's a lifesaver typically
doesn't sound super consistent anyway I
met a guy I met this guy unhinge and we
went on a date together it was the best
night I've ever had we had a ton of fun
together he followed up immediately and
asked me to get lunch during work two
times the following week we eventually
had another amazing night together where
I met some of his friends and slept over
we texted everyday talked to almost
every hour however for the last two
weeks I can feel something is off
because he cancels plans he organizes
with me a responds to casual text hours
later and says he's been super busy at
work I distance myself and eventually
last week asked if there was something
that altered his outlook on me again he
said no and that has just been super
busy but wants me to see me before we
start school keep in mind I always see
him on social media but his friends
hanging out what do I do or do I do I
say something to him when he reaches out
again here's the thing and like it's
hard when you're in it to see this but
sometimes when you start dating someone
like it's too much too soon
too bad like then all of us you guys
went on one date two weeks later it
seems as if you are his girlfriend and
it's like friends he was just on hinge
like he's freaking out because that's
what boys do because they're immature as
[ __ ] and you kind of have to like ease
into these things it's as our friend
Danny says it starts to stink like fish
is that what she says yeah I just got
your reference sorry no I had another
thought this is the same thing we said
last week with your toasters it's like a
no relationship like this boys are so
[ __ ] stupid
literally the only thing you got to do
to make it work in your favor is just be
illusive stop answering like don't be so
available like the way you're feeling
now without him is the way he should
feel about you like you don't respond to
his texts you'd like it's so simple like
playing games is stupid but when you're
at a certain age and a boy is playing a
game you have to play back if you want
to win stop [ __ ] answering him don't
be so available like Jubilee What's
Wrong babe like let him ask you what's
wrong and also like he's
your boyfriend yes so I my go-to would
be like you can't have that conversation
of it's everything okay like if you feel
it in your stomach that something's not
right something's not right drugs to
your gut
he's a piece of [ __ ] and yeah you had a
good time with him but it's easy to have
a good time with someone when you don't
know them all you guys do is talk about
service-level things and drink and have
a good time like so you can have that
with someone else it's really like who's
there the next morning for you and it
doesn't seem like it's this guy I would
keep going out with other people
he'll probably come around but by then
it'll be too late and you sound like a
great gal so just get back out there and
this is a very normal thing
unfortunately because boys are pieces of
[ __ ] boys like girls can be the worst
but boys are really the [ __ ] worst
well because it's like I could just see
this guy it's like he joined him she's
like he's trying to play the field all
of a sudden he's wifed up and it's like
it doesn't matter how great you are it's
like this isn't what I signed up for
right you know like I wanted to go I
wanted to date for a while cuz guys
don't think like girls do like oh wow
this connection is something special I
should usually my app right yeah girls
get really ahead of them they're like oh
this connection connection is something
special I can go find more of those on
hinge if you listen to one thing I said
on today's show elusive 'ti is key need
to be elusiveness is key stop [ __ ]
answering [ __ ] are still available
these days and guys don't want that like
it's lame as it sounds like they want
what they can't have so give them what
they can't have
right and then we said it last year
toasters make yourself scarce
yes car city is case scar City is key
and it's like I don't like people who
play games like you don't have to play
hard to get but just play busy right
like pretend like you have a life right
and like you've got [ __ ] going on you're
going on other dates too that's the key
and people who like it's so hard to find
a man people don't know this and that's
what I'm trying to educate like it's not
that hard
honestly that episode of seconds said he
put it perfectly either a he's just not
been Incheon which is fine not everyone
has to like everyone tn Colton like
sometimes it just doesn't work out to
elusiveness okay yeah you gotta you
gotta finesse when I was dating Bennet
it was like things were rocky my friend
at least his mom told me something and
she was like it's a genius
she's like you have to ignore men shake
my husband calls me Mom times day
sometimes I pick up sometimes I don't
you gotta ignore men it was the best
advice ever dog and also like in Sex in
the City when they're talking about men
are like taxis and it's just all about
timing like you can have that like a
media connection with someone and if
he's so a like he if he has been on
hinge for years and he's been
waiting for this like then you guys are
this and it's great but like it's just
not his time you know it's just not his
time could truer words have never been
spoken Jackie thank you
wow we got so much done today and we're
right on time we've drain of minutes
anybody want to say anything else um I
know you do much mushroom paradise so
I'll just recap it in two minutes I'm
sorry who did I know it's so bad and the
editing last night was out of control
they were having they were showing like
Jordan saying something and then cutting
to analyse and it's like clear that
they're not talking to each other there
was just like making conversations and
they're just making [ __ ] up and that's a
new level this goes back to my point
yesterday so Caroline money came in and
she is first of all she was so nervous
she was so cute she like didn't know how
to ask to go to the bathroom she and
she's like standing there in front of
the cameras and trying to talk to Joe
she's like can I just like it was so
funny she's so cute
and so a lot of the guys are taken or
suck and she winds up asking out John
the Ben mo guy okay and they have a
really nice time and like she was just
like I usually just go for jocks and I
just want to try something different so
she was really being open and she had a
good time in the next day she's like
excited about it and then they bring in
Judah Lee who's there to date Jon - and
they're like two nerds and they're
perfect together and they have a great
date and it's like you're gonna [ __ ]
over a great girl like that like what
are you what are you trying to happen in
paradise like what what they don't want
any matches right and it's like the
point that the premise of paradise is
inherently [ __ ] up because you get to
stay if you have a connection therefore
leaving fewer and fewer people who were
actually looking to make connection it's
such a good point you know like at a
certain point like Jade and Tanner
should have gone to a honeymoon suite
and bring in two people totally like you
we need the freshness it gets like
really stale Marcus and Lacey and
they're just I I can't stress it enough
there are so many eligible legitimate
girls there
Tia Caroline now baby onna like that is
so she the boy I honestly I missed you
Belize so much I forgot how much I liked
her she's from Benton season and like I
know she's warming and she's such a nerd
and her and I'm like actually had a cute
date and I enjoyed it as much as I could
even though like I have a pit waiting
for him back at the house right and who
didn't even the root of Chelsea nobody
even the rose last week I think just a
friend okay um and it's like none of
these girl like we need better guys and
I figured out the reason why the guy
stuck oh my god I figured it out it's
the timing because the Bachelorette just
ended and now there were [ __ ]
couple of eligible guys from Mecca
season but they're all waiting around to
become the bachelor that they're not
going on paradise so if we had Jason
there if we even had Blake there and
then like then Higgins might go on right
might be the bachelor like he would be
great in paradise and because all these
guys are from Beca season they're new
they're like fresh too like this z-list
Fame and they're not wrong I have a
girlfriend they're trying to like DM a
hookers in every city that they go to
and like have sex with that like they're
not really there for the right reasons
because they're loving this newfound
fame and the few quality guys from her
season are waiting to become the
bachelor so they're not gonna go to
paradise because they don't want to seem
thirsty and that didn't work for anyone
except Nick vile because for some reason
his thirst was rewarded however all the
eligible bachelorettes from Ari season
already found out they weren't going to
be the Bachelorette and now they're
ready to go and then and so they went so
it really is a contradiction and to tell
them that's why we have like the worst
crop of guys because the good guys want
to be the bachelor right Cole so the
timing we gotta ship the timing that's
why they should be announcing they
should announce the bachelor and after
the final rose
they shouldn't wait till September so
the guys who know they're not gonna be
the bachelor can go on paradise and
because the guys who aren't the bachelor
then spend the next year being thirsty
showing their true colors and by the
time they go empowered everyone died
said their piece of [ __ ] anyway so like
that's what I'm with Robbie right that's
such a good call look I I figured it all
out I feel like they should switch it up
like they should swap where the bachelor
is and the where the Bachelorette is so
that by the time it's paradise the boys
know because really like all the girls
come on the show are like quality girls
like some of them are annoying but like
for the most part they really do all
like want relationships and so you no
matter who it's gonna be even if it's
not like the final three that didn't
make it you're still gonna get good
girls yeah good call so we got to get
those eligible bachelors for the
bachelor to be on paradise that's the
only way we're gonna even the playing
field then we're gonna get some real
connections and they should be
announcing The Bachelor before people go
to Paradise so that they know what's up
like even Peter's in the running for
being the bachelor like he could go on
paradise you know he's the 2-butene he's
always like waiting to see if the
bachelor is gonna meet him not propose
okay I agree with your formula but I
don't agree that it applies to me
because
Peter wouldn't go even if they never
offered him though even if they said
Jenn you were never going to be the
bachelor he would not go on paradise I
agree but even like last season Eric was
number three and I go to paradise
because there was a shot he would have
been great in paradise last season but
now when I came on our show and it was
like the week before they announced it
he really thought
great and so that's why he didn't go to
paradise but if he went to paradise last
season and people still remembered him
as the guy who was like so ready to
propose to Rachel instead of now like
this goofball doing like the Carlton
with a podcast actually hilarious like
it was such a good point it would have
been better last season so we gotta get
the bachelor announce sooner so that the
losers or the non bachelors can go to
Paradise and meet the girls who also
could have been bachelorettes but
weren't like Tina could have been the
Bachelorette right great and if we had
first and when the aired when the
bachelor did Tia wouldn't have gone to
Paradise because she thought she might
have still been the Bachelorette right I
figured it all out that's my paradise
makes no goddamn sense on a number of
levels and that's why they're always
pulling people from like random seasons
and the editing doesn't help also what
we didn't touch on yesterday that I
wanted to touch on is amaz your shot out
to Lukey she is the whole show
I need more Yuuki I need a Yuki spin-off
with her and walls I agree with Cara
Highland yeah like Wells and you care
bluer the only people I can stand and
they never get on the show I agree and I
guess Wells is being like faced outing
Yuki will be the number one Barton look
how bulb is about more tender in this
group how bored as Wells I mean he's got
it made in the shade like he has a
blossoming career he has a great
relationship with like a legitimate
celebrity and he can like come in and
out of Baxter franchise as he sees fit
he gets his phone in paradise but I was
gonna say he definitely has a phone in
Paradise yeah he really like he did it
right the whole thing good job yeah
honestly good job and moved so funniest
because the way he came into the
franchise it was like so awkward he made
it really far and Joe just use it and
they never kissed and then they had that
really awkward kiss that though for
every time which is that horrible show
that nobody it's like a New York
attraction do not go but they went like
overseas ya know like to the authentic
I'm sure that one was good it was like
cuz anyway in some Spanish country so
like it was really authentic yes that's
so funny okay well we're back tomorrow
but I'm not I'm in Raleigh North
Carolina tomorrow I do believe that she
I was sold out but there might be like
one or two VIP tickets left I don't
remember you just head to girl with my
job calm Hasbrouck Heights New Jersey
next week just check it out you know
it's gonna be good time yes and if you
are interested in camcos tickets
the Eventbrite is at the link in our bio
the password is premium all caps come
alone bring a friend your friend doesn't
even have to be a toaster don't worry we
will convert her yeah total it's gonna
be like a lot of toes
but also just like good camp fun it's
gonna be a fun weekend like aren't you
they're just looking for fun because
different fun different fact if ''tis
hobbies yes maybe I'll pick up a new
hobby canoeing jet skiing kayaking
whatever I can't with the ropes course
I'm in it rock climbing I'm gonna me
there's a rock wall I'm gonna I'm going
to need a personal golf cart just like
to drive me around camp cuz like it's
kind of big grounds and I'm kind of
tired no I think that's it we work that
into our contract dude wait okay we got
a lot of them um thank you guys so much
for watching the number one morning show
the Millennial morning show I just feel
like not enough people know about the
morning shows and it's on our viewers
just convert tick every week to convert
one person we double our audience every
week you know just convert Sally at the
watercooler convert one of your friends
like I feel like millenials don't watch
morning television cuz like what the
hell do they need to be watching the
view for like and those Lucas how can
you watch at work right they don't
really talk about things you really care
about they don't recap shows you really
care about and that's why we literally
that's why we created the morning toast
it's the millennial Morning Show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
every day we're very accessible but you
can watch us on Facebook so make sure to
like us there you can watch us on
youtubes make sure to subscribe to us
there but then if you're a commuter or
if you just enjoy podcasting we're also
available on the podcast app at the
morning chose to so if you have an
Android you can also listen on
soundcloud we make it easy
yeah also like a great tip when
someone's just like complaining about
work which I feel like if the group of
friends everyone is because work sucks
like instead of like trying to coach him
for it through it just be like watch the
morning toast it'll change your whole
day and then by the way watch a morning
show so you've got like two hours out of
your way and then join the morning
toasters Facebook group which is for the
toasters the fans the followers the
listeners just to talk about like
breaking news in pop culture sharing
stories about like makeup like there's
just you could there's as well fill your
hole there's well you could fill your
whole day with just actual episodes of
the toast and being active in the
toaster community and if you convert a
new toaster then they get to watch old
episodes of the toes so it's really
worth it thank you guys so much for
being so supportive for watching every
day we love you I'm back Monday Jackie's
back tomorrow peace
you